no I think it's basically fundamental in
terms of been much is given much is
expected to be given back and returned
and there's so much people can consume
in terms of wealth and require in terms
of wealth if one has been blessed or
been fortunate enough to have got much
more than normal wealth it is but
natural that one expects a certain
finish for irresponsibility in terms of
how that wealth is applied used and
leveraged for purposes of society
you know I think the the concept of the
strong linkage to the family is breaking
down in Western nations to the
obligations which I think to the clinics
are not only Indian but a people feel
towards their families is much less in
terms of Western people and particularly
American people so when you take a
philosophy approach that you do not have
to leave well to your families you
they'd have to tell yourself do you take
it to the grave or do you rate it for
some more worthwhile purpose and this
also reflects in the way that families
get structured you know children live
separately children put old parents into
homes instead of putting them into their
homes for the children expect from the
parents and what the parents expect from
the children
we've been focusing on primary education
in India for the past nine years both in
wipro limited as well as in the
foundation we set up or I set up you you
had to make a bet the way you think you
could really make a contribution but you
could really build a depth understanding
so we were very clear from the day one
that we had to have a focus to is it had
to be a cause which was relevant to the
country in terms of need a critical
course in terms of need were you saw a
gap between what could be and what is
and three it should be an area where it
should have an access beyond just a
specific educating of a child we
concluded that if we could educate
children better in our country you would
have better citizens but importantly we
also realized that if you educate the
girl child when she grows up and starts
a family she has a smaller family which
is a refuge requirement in terms of the
growth of our population which is more
manageable and three again if you
educate the girl child when she grows up
and she starts a family or looks after a
household she has much higher
consciousness on primary health care
I think you know what you must
understand is the state of education in
India you have one side the cities which
have very good schools average schools
and not so good school the level of
education in these cities is fairly good
they get fairly good teachers on the
other side you have the villages of
India way sixty-five to seventy percent
of the people of India live and there we
have education which is in the villages
and ninety percent of that education is
run by the state governments a partly
funded by the central government where
the state government does not charge any
fees gives free uniforms gives a free
mid-day meal which is very often the
best meal the child gets and where there
are six million unionized teachers in
the States government multiple state
governments which we have across the
country standards of Education they are
very very low the commitment of the
teachers is very very low the quality of
the teacher the training of the teachers
is very very low so does an enormous
amount one can do to upgrade the quality
of teaching the quality of the teachers
the way the curricula is actually learn
the way it is facilitated to be learned
the way you can community intervene to
get community breakers building up on
the education system to demand certain
standards the way you can train the
teacher training institute there are 600
districts in India every district in
India has a teacher training institute
and every teacher in the state
government school requires to spend 15
days of retraining in these Institute's
most of these Institute's are in
shambles and many of them have teachers
who are worse than the teachers they're
supposed to teach so this enormous
amount of leverage one can do in terms
of upgrading this entire infrastructure
for which the government spends a lot of
money there's an enormous amount one can
do in training and upgrading the quality
of the state functionaries that's
precisely what we do in our foundation
and we have been successful now because
we have been working for nine years in
this we involved now with over two and a
half million children